hey leute was geht am herzen kommen zu
diesen spontanen video ich werde jetzt
an einen badesee fahren wo unter anderem
levy dave und noch ein paar andere leute
sind und werde die post oder pause zu
machen wie im prinzip bedeutet jemand
sagt du dir pause und du musst sofort
aufhören zu tun was du tust und stehen
bleibt heißt wenn gerade über die straße
gehst seit wenn du gerade an der
supermarktkasse bist oder wenn sie
beispielsweise schwimmen zuerst habe ich
das bei brent reiber gesehen
dementsprechend alles gegeben jetzt kann
ich guten gewissens klauen
ich bin da so leute wären jetzt auch
abgeholt und im auto vor uns sitzen
regie phillip dorset und dave ist jetzt
auf dem weg zum see und dann fangen auch
gleich an mit der post challenge so
leute wie sie jetzt am strand angeführt
haben wir gerade von der badeinsel schon
ein video für morgen gedreht
da müsst ihr unbedingt auch mal
vorbeischauen das richtig lustig
geworden und ich würde sagen die change
beginnt jetzt das heißt ihr könnt
jederzeit die kamera ist auch ihr könnt
euch jederzeit die kamera gut und eben
diese sachen machen also einfach pause
sagen und dann ja jetzt verstanden ok
los geht's so max hauser
egal ob hat so
dies ist gegenüber stehe ja auch hier
winken jetzt überstehen musste noch
halten
[Musik]
ja es war keiner hier
das widerstehen
ok
die ganze debatte dem ok
[Musik]
den spaß am volleyball die tat nicht
das gefährt ist leute
ok mal zweiter
[Musik]
[Applaus]
künftig umfeld
wie war das noch
ihre regierung heute
gerade wenn draußen der opfer ausgewählt
ich brauche
den mund
mit dem vor einigen wochen missbraucht
stadt noch rang acht
weiter leute wie gerettet
ich würde eine länge verteilt wirklich
kurz favoritensterben abend weiter dann
zählt man nicht so anderer weiter dann
würde ich sagen dass ich aufhören doch
auch ohne dass wir weiter sagt okay aber
lasst uns dass man diesem stück habe die
axpo beiträge ja da kommt das heißt wird
das wieder ihren los dass die messe
ich freue mich dass er nicht antwort
ganz einfach weiter
er muss eigentlich auch nicht zu atmen
gesagt haben und sogar noch sprechen da
habe ich leider konnte
was machen wir
das ist ein wenig gegenliebe
euro
diese frage auch die anderen stars
gegeneinander
da sie ja voll den nachteil hat die
hauptfragen
die tore schoss
und glücklich
sie hatten alle deutlichen nachteil der
eindruck und dafür bekommen
so leute wir sind fertig am strand und
sind jetzt einkaufen
das kann nicht gut enden oh ja die
anderen sind jetzt wird's richtig
gedanken die jungs das kann man nicht
machen
weiter
sein
nein
die beiden waren nicht allein die türken
aber fängt ja schon jemand an zu zittern
nach einem gegner
max
so schwarz weiter
die lustigen war dabei
ich muss da rein und haben sagen ich
glaube da muss irgendwie ein bisschen
sollten dann noch mal was raus
warum kommt man schon mal
jetzt okay das ist lustig liga das ist
witzig energieverschwendung ist immer so
das ist nicht lustig macht das ding noch
zu entschuldigen sie
wir machen das ganz genau entschuldigen
sie sich wirklich etwas aus dem rahmen
wir sind dann an der kasse vorbei und
ich glaube das hat er aber der musste
zum glück noch mal rein und was
abzuwägen und ich haben wir rein sagt
ott
[Musik]
warum warum was ich mache urlaub braun
nein noch nicht
so konnte sie erst bei mir angekommen
die gesehen gibt es diese pracht das ist
der sebastian ist auch wieder dabei und
so viel ich weiß ja auch so etwas hier
okay leute danach habe ich nicht mehr
weiter gefilmt wir müssen ein bisschen
anders aus und wenn auch gerade
unterwegs ich wollte ich noch eine sache
zeigen weil ich davon ausgehe dass es
wahrscheinlich in den kommentaren
auftaucht und zwar um die bank groß vor
einem tag zu dem zeitpunkt wo das video
jetzt anderen kommt auch ein video
hochgeladen und der fantasie mega
ähnlich aus wie mainz das ist aber
wirklich ein zufall
ich hab meins nämlich schon viel früher
gemacht so dass sie also auch in einem
see und auch mit fernbedienung wie es
das und dann ist mir aufgefallen die
bank groß und vor allem tag dann ist mir
aufgefallen dass sie das einfach 11
geklaut haben bei einem amerikanischen
kanal bei marks der das vor einer woche
hochgeladen und sie haben einfach
eiskalt ihr gesicht reingemacht geht
wenn ich das mal lustig also in der hier
mal schaut es der 23 juni und hier ist
meine familie datei klicken wir auf
information und die ist vom 19 juni
keine habe ich wollte immer zeigen mit
dem frank rost fand ich sehr lustig wenn
ihr davon teil 2 wollt schreibt gern die
kommentare ansonsten bank fürs zu sehen
und bis zum nächsten mal tschüss